so you you really think that the origin
of of life on earth
is a really special event yeah if it did
originate on earth my question for those
that search for life outside the earth
is what if you had a letter from god and
the letter said um life didn't originate
on earth like would you choose a
different profession like it would seem
hopeless like in other words we only
have a sample of one in fact we only
know of one conscious life form let
alone one planet that has life on it
right what if you knew for sure it
didn't start here that means that like
there's almost nothing about earth that
is um originated it didn't originate the
life process so to study purely the
origin of life not life itself i think
that's still fascinating but how could
we learn about you know the origin of of
remember you have to go from inanimate
object to a living object whatever that
definition of life is and i'm not an
expert and there are many definitions
max sarah you know many different uh
definitions but
but how do you actually go from from
from inanimate to anime it's a huge
question yeah but then you don't have to
be the place where life originated to
replicate the origin or to under like uh
yeah that's one way to understand
something is to
uh build it yeah but another way is to
just observe it you don't have to truly
re-uh re-engineer from scratch
so
you know i
but then yes if it didn't originate on
earth then your intuitions about the
basic prerequisites of life are are off
what's the governing principle right
like me what is uh and then you could
have just an almost an arbitrary number
of possible like
if life didn't start on earth
to me that's exciting because it's like
we know even less than we thought
the thing is it can prosper on earth
though
yeah so maybe the origin of life is
fundamentally different from
the maintenance of life right and maybe
maybe the existence of the earth life
symbiosis is critical i think sarah you
talked about sarah walker um
that it's a planetary phenomenon etc so
doesn't that make it less like in other
words like not only do you need special
life conditions to create life but then
sustenance of life as you say that also
has to be
maintained under very specific
circumstances by very specific planets
and with very specific tectonic activity
and moon and by the way you need a
jupiter nearby you need an earth and a
moon system so that you don't get
bombarded too early and i always think
like this like technological life i
haven't said this before really
something i'm just speaking i usually
like to write down before i say
different things but one of the things i
thought about somebody hosts a podcast
you should probably accept the fact that
you're going to say stupid things every
once in a while not every once in a
while every while i claim that you know
to get to
sending you know people to the moon
you know our planet needed whales and
and dinosaurs right like you don't make
a solar panel from another solar panel
like you made a solar panel from a
factory that melted down glass silica
you know aluminum extruded that using
fossil fuels where do those fossil fuels
come from like so
any civilization that's gonna be a dyson
you know kardashev
did they have dinosaurs like do they
have like prebiotic life do they have a
great oxygenation event did they have a
dimorphism between prokaryotic eukaryote
all those hurdles they give each one
let's say there's eight hurdles
and each one of those has a probability
of one in a thousand to go from you know
eukaryotic prokaryote whatever let's say
there's a one in a thousand chance i
think it's like one in 10 to the 40th or
whatever if you really do it but let's
say it's first generous nature one in
ten to the three
let's say there's eight of those hurdles
that means you have you know 10 to the
to the uh to the 24th power
uh different uh
possibility and that's just with eight
like the moon has to be there jupiter
has to be there dinosaurs had to be
there all the different things that we
have to get to technological life
there's only 10 to the 2 only there's 10
to the 22nd we think earth not earth
planets in the observable universe not
the galaxy
so that's a hundred times fewer than the
probability to get you know 100 percent
clearing these eight very low hurdles of
one and a thousand that's fascinating
because now i really need to listen to
your conversation with lee cronin who i
believe
because he believes the opposite yes i
know yeah i want to have a debate with
him
he believes
that
the the way biology evolved on earth
could have evolved almost an infinite
number of other ways so like if you ran
earth over and over and over you would
keep getting life and it'll be very
different
so it's
the the fact that our
particular life seems unique
is just like well because every freaking
life is gonna seem unique but it'll be
very different it's not like we
shouldn't be asking the question of
what's the likelihood of getting a
human-like thing
because that seems to be super special
it's more like
um
how easy is it to make slime
anything that has the skills of a human
and i don't mean like something with
thumbs but
achieving basically a technological
civilization and according to lee at
least it's like it's it's trivial i know
we fought i fought a little bit i'd love
to debate him and i think it'd be a lot
of fun because we debate with love when
i talk with lee i love him and he loves
me i think i hope
you